[Music]
ah love you got to love it everywhere
you look there it is but in the city
that never sleeps how do you really know
who the hell you're sleeping with people
can conceal some very dirty
secrets or fat
fatal
flaws beautiful everything's
fine Joy's just loudly shattering
Seaglass to put in her aquarium sure
sure uh have you asked your new fiance
about the lipstick yet did she write
pig on Ben dressing her mirror
yeah no but I will Charles you said you
would ask her 2 days ago let us in we
could talk to her I am handling the
situation in my own time see I told you
he didn't need our help but I do did
does this scarf say Loretta I've loved
you since the first day I met you I
don't know what the scarf is saying but
all I can see is a crayon box ah well
see that's why we always carry a
backup thank you Mabel Charles I can
calmly talk to Joy you know investigate
her woman to suspect woman she has not
another Jan I think she could be but
it's important for me to be able to
interrogate my murderous girlfriend
fiance what about my hair is it
giving Karen or ker Grant hold
on Baba Mora are you going out on a date
no no no tobert has a suspect he has a
lead on I'm meeting him for a stake out
and the place has a dress code well it's
the date yeah it's a stake out when two
totally platonic semi-professional
investigators wait together and an out
of site in closed space and watch while
a suspect hopefully incriminates
themselves while we holding our PE for
hours and eat stale Cheetos in a
cocktail dress look I'm going to unmute
your text I'll be in the wings if
anything should go
Haywire I'll be
okay is it possible you're sleeping next
to a lunatic or a liar sure it
is but I always tell people better to
lose your mind loving than to live your
life Loveless it's been a while since I
dipped my quill in a woman's ink pot any
new moves I should know about please
don't make me take the next
[Music]
one